a trail of Carnage extending hundreds of
yards down the tracks the survivors of
this nightmare crawl to safety through
Twisted Metal the express passenger
train was traveling at around 80 miles
an hour when it slammed into a
stationary freight train derailing
multiple cars before striking a second
passenger train it's India's worst rail
disaster this Century officials say it
was probably a signal failure and many
people are angry the country has a
massive rail network relied on by over
20 million passengers a day
families are still searching for their
loved ones a grim troll through the
morgue
this man lost his brother newly married
and with a young son
I haven't told our mother he says she
won't be able to handle this news